[Music]
this is neil duketa from toronto ontario
canada
my question for you is what are your
first three actionable steps to creating
a lead gen business and what are the
three industries you would uh go after
in small communities
okay we could do that
it's hard to come up with three but i
think we could just talk about it in
general
well i i got all right i got into this
business a little bit i was testing on a
legion site what i did was
i emailed another legion site and i just
said would you buy leads from me
how much
and they said if your leads were
qualified using these parameters we will
pay you a hundred dollars per lead is
for a trucking website that i was
working on and they said if they are
uh long
commercial driver licensed folks and you
are able to verify that by getting a
picture of their license we will give
you one hundred dollars
and so i assumed a hundred dollars was
the cheapest that it would cost and then
if i i also went on linkedin and i
emailed
the marketing and growth managers at the
actual trucking companies and i said how
much do you guys pay and they said 150
and that kind of gave me that range of i
can acquire it for 100 to 150
and then what i did was i went and
drove ads and traffic to a website that
got this information and i was able to
get leads for 250 and i thought huh okay
if i just if i just fooled around and
got it for 250 bucks
and they're willing to pay 150 like i
think there's something there that i can
actually make this profitable that's
what i did
yeah i think
my first step would be because i don't
know a ton about legion i'd be like okay
well
who's killing it with legion and so i
would just my first step would be like
find a blueprint
of success uh so who is who is a newish
lead gen site so i wouldn't be looking
for one that like started in 1998 and
has just been cranking since then i'd be
like all right what's a newish lead gen
site so something started maybe the last
two three years
and i would go look at their stuff i
could read an article about them and
then i would contact them and be like
hey
um really interested in your business um
and i'd either be like i'm interested in
buying your business
can you tell me a little about it would
you be open if you know at the right
price would you be open to selling your
business and they sell yes or no
or i would say hey um
i'm really trying to learn about the
lead gen business for a different
category
would you um
you know would you be down to you know
talk to me for 15 20 minutes whatever
and they might say yes they might say no
if i wanted to make it juicier i could
say hey i'm doing an article on my
favorite five you know truck truck
driver lead gen businesses or truck
driver
recruiting businesses uh i want to
feature you guys
um just need to hop on a call 30 minutes
i'll ask you a few questions and i'll
use it in the article and then in that
you know
article i would basically while doing
that that call about the article i would
ask them how they started how they get
it you know how they get the leads um
what's the hardest part blah blah blah
and i would try to figure out a
blueprint to figure out is this even the
business i want to be in and is there a
common formula that these businesses use
like oh they all use facebook ads as
their traffic source or they all use
google keywords as their traffic source
then they take you to a landing page
with a quick email capture and then
three question qualifier right after
that and then their business models that
they sell those leads to whoever at
certain price and this only works if the
leads are like you know 100 worth 100 or
more the ones that are below that seem
to struggle and i would try to figure
out how much money they make and how
they do it and that'll be my first first
thing is i'd be searching for a
blueprint essentially that i can
remix it's like all right i'm gonna 80
is going to be the same and 20 is going
to be different so the 20 that's
different might be i'm in a different
category or i do it from a slightly
different like you know
i put a greater emphasis on copywriting
or newsletters or whatever in order to
generate those leads that would be my
first first step
and which industry
so we have a couple examples here so you
did
you did trucking on your own before that
you've shown me an apartment one what
was it apartment
what was the lead gen for well um
what leads did they want the company
that bought my company years ago was
called apartment list originally they
were called vertical brands and they
just owned lead gen sites for
senior
living um they owned a legion site for a
rent to own housing which was like they
bootstrapped i think like six or seven
million in revenue then they owned
apartment list which eventually became
the main company but that was a lead gem
for apartments and then they
owned it for cars called autolist.com
which was acquired by car gurus for like
30 million dollars
and so that was really effective uh but
i would the math is basically like
how valuable of a purchase price is the
product
multiplied by
the frequency that they
one person buys the product
multiplied by the number of people who
have that need so for example if it's a
lead gen for ceos of large of like small
to medium-sized businesses so it's like
a job board for potential ceos
a small business would be one to spend
like 50 000 on that
and but they're only gonna hire once
every eight years so like that kind of
gives you like help and there's like not
that many people who are into that that
kind of gives you like the math behind
the opportunity do you know what i mean
yeah exactly i'd be looking for high
ticket price things so i was going to
say senior living my father-in-law does
senior living and i see that like he
wants customers a customer to him is
going to pay maybe six grand a month
for
a room so their customer
you know and they'll last on average you
know two years at the place right so
you're getting 24 months times six
thousand dollars their va customers are
very valuable they're willing to give
you six thousand dollars for a
you know for a customer if you can send
them one so their leads might be you
know a few hundred bucks that they're
willing to pay for if you're qualified
right if you're in the area and whatever
else so senior living was one i was
gonna say um and then the other ones are
like you know i see this with like
moving companies or construction
companies or like pool construction
companies like oh that's a 50 000
project to build a pool in this area and
maybe the pool construction companies
are not the best at seo like
optimization so i'm going to go after
that category because i think that
that's that's one where i can i can beat
them at their own game and sell them
back those those customer leads um so i
would look for really high ticket price
uh things like moving pool construction
senior uh you know senior care
um
there's one more that i was thinking of
that's uh
all right slip my mind but yeah things
like that i think those are those are
great categories to go after
i can't find this client info have you
heard of hubspot hubspot is a crm
platform so it shares its data across
every application every team can stay
aligned no out of sync spreadsheets or
dueling databases hubspot grow better
can i share one that i just heard about
that i actually think would be pretty
valuable here
is um
because it's related to what you were
saying about senior care facilities
there's this new kind of facility that's
coming online that's essentially like
um
mental health triage i think is the way
to think of it which is essentially like
you walk in and there's a bunch of lazy
boys and they've got tvs in front of
them and if you're having like an
episode a mental breakdown you go in
there and
they
might help medicate you if you need that
and they'll set you up with a therapist
on this big tv and just like make sure
you're okay while people figure out
what's going on uh because mental health
issues are becoming more prevalent uh
okay so this is like actually just
coming online uh and this is like a new
type of care facility and i feel like
there's probably not a lot of
competition yet for
um
finding those types of leads um so there
might be some uh
some opportunities to to
help
that's a good question uh
i know my buddy dennis is like helping
build one so he he told me about it but
i don't know what you would call them
yeah
mental health care treatment or
something like that but like i think
that you know the general principle is
you want a high ticket uh you know buyer
of your leads so you need them to be
making a ton of money off of the thing
you want to have low competition if
possible the other thing is can you use
content
as like your legion so you're not just
playing a google keywords bidding game
or a facebook ads keyword bidding game
but like if you
are educating people about something so
like i don't know let's call it like um
what's that like surgery that a bunch of
people getting like brazilian booty
lifts or something like that it's like
there's some surgery or some new thing
that a bunch of people are curious about
right
and uh the topic itself like kind of
lends itself to content or ratings or
reviews or like
uh you know
pros and cons and stuff like that like
um
can you create youtube or tick tock
content that's just talking about you
know the pros the cons the the good
stories the horror stories the whatever
else and then basically if people and
then you capture interested parties who
are like they were googling to try to
learn more about it and you as the
educational source become like you know
slightly trusted you never need to
operate the underlying business you just
sell that lead
you know farm them to a partner who's
basically like you know your vetted
partner to do that that procedure or do
that or do whatever it is in a given
geography
[Music]
sid
did we answer that ben
i think it's a good ass answer
that's it one question friday
all right uh and uh if you want your
question read live on uh on the show
go to mfmpod.com and click on the
microphone ask us questions
bye
[Music]
you